a lot of us get asked to host events but
you were asked to host an event for the
Pope yes is that true
yes it is true and and what it's and
this is like what can award show he was
it's the festival of families so every
year they have it in the major city and
this year it was in Philadelphia during
his tour of the United States and was
one of those things where it literally
happened like I was in church a guy came
to speak and he started asking are you a
participant or your spectator do you
really get involved in the community and
the parish and I'm like oh wow I guess I
better start doing more yeah that's one
of those questions where you're she's
you know you're supposed to say I would
probably say I'm a spectator leave me
well ya know normally you know you put
your hand in the pocket but it was
wasn't that and then all of a sudden I'm
standing I'm praying and a guy tapped me
on the shoulder and says hey would you
be an usher I'm like no and I'm like no
yes of course I will be I have to do
more you know I started doing the
collection and I was like wow that's
pretty cool and then literally the next
week guys came up to me and said they
wanted me to host the festival of
families with the Pope and it was
terrifying because I'm not good at like
reading teleprompters and right know
this they were honoring these amazing
families from all over the world and I
don't want to be like mispronouncing
names and stuff like that but also it's
the Pope so you know for Catholics it's
a huge deal and you get to meet him did
you tie did I met the Holy Father and he
had no idea who I was
yes like movie theaters were watching TV
I think since the 70s so probably wanted
Erik Estrada to host it he was still
very polite and I was surprised because
he kept asking me you know he just kept
saying pray for me oh my god you're in
pretty good yeah you're a lot buddy I
mean I need the prayers but uh but it
was a special it was a special
experience
were you kind of in a way relieved that
he wasn't familiar with all of your work
there are a few movies that I am
definitely hoping that God is the movies
you know movies like Boogie Nights
they're gonna there's gonna be some
explaining there yeah but he was like I
love Boogie Nights that would have been
bad but that was this young boy who was
singing he was probably 11 or 12 years
old and he had this angelic voice I mean
he's singing gospel he was deaf
absolutely amazing and then all of a
sudden you know he comes up gets it gets
an award from the Father and then he's
walking by me and I said wow you have an
amazing voice because I love Ted to see
Ted did I get quickly apologized and I
asked the father on stage to say a
little prayer for me because I know I've
made some movies that are probably
questionable in the eyes of all the good
Lord yeah yeah I think he just covered
yourself well that was good
you